grâce à la pandémie pendant un an et
demi deux ans je n'ai pas entendu la
phrase où est le week-end dernier on a
fait le v g2 jérôme
enterrement dit garçon enterrement des
junkies tu m'embrasses que c'est un vga
vga fin et je pense que c'est vraiment
le fléau du 21e siècle je pense qu'on
s'est trompé d'ennemis avec le gluten
pendant un temps mais sincèrement il est
là le choc des civilisations manger 33
ans donc hors pandémie j'en ai une
semaine sur deux plus j'en fais moi je
comprends le concept cette idée pour
lancer quelqu'un dans les meilleures
conditions d'un mariage de kidnapper
cette personne de l'emmener dans une des
plus belles villes d'europe qui seront
apportées d'easyjet et une fois sur
place était à 4 g 8 pendant 36 heures tu
vois rien du tout tu aurais tu es ça
avec une boule à facettes et une tireuse
à bière dans une cave à dunkerque
c'était la même chose
vg veillait je supporte pas les gens qui
les disent forme d'acronyme mais j'aime
ça c'est réparé zemit l'acronyme tout le
temps pour faire pouvons comprendre aux
gens que vous avez pas le times moi j'ai
croisé une pote ya quelques mois dans
les rues qui m'a dit vous êtes entendus
pour magali fnts pour tentative de
suicide même si vous n'avez pas le temps
de le dire dans d'autres zones qu on vj
vj
que tu l'écris sous forme d'acronyme
parce que c'est long j'entends les gens
qui le disent avec leur bouche si on a
ce soir dans la salle cuit vous tous
font la fête une ts pour voir puis c'est
pas bon parce que moi à chaque fois
qu'on me dit le vg j'entends ivg sheila
est allé fêter son avortement à budapest
fans écoutent sympa ouais super je
déteste les photos dans tellement vie de
jeune fille ça m'agace sur un facebook
instagram et serrage des signes à tout
est confirmé leur congrès un arbre les
jeux
200 structures des photos enterrement de
vie de jeune fille toujours un peu la
même structure c'est toujours une espèce
de crabes de 8 kaunas sur les ramblas
comme ça elle dessert tête en forme de
beats et des t-shirts qu'elles ont fait
imprimer pour l'occasion de sceller
louloute à charles a tenu trois réunions
charlotte
l'enterrement du garçon félicitations
messieurs beaucoup moins agaçant comment
sa question beaucoup plus dangereux en
revanche sous couvert de rigolade
parfois ses limites maltraitance le truc
quand même je comprends pas chaque fois
que j'ai un pote qui me raconte son
enterrement de vie de garçon c'est
toujours un truc genre alors c'était un
truc de malade on avait juré il en avait
six mois à quatre heures du matin ils
m'ont réveillé avec de l'huile chaude
ensuite ils m'ont mis nu dans une
camionnette avec des furets vivant en a
compté jusqu'à amsterdam
évidemment ils m'ont foutu un coup de
bâtiments tube est la vôtre car j'ai
perdu connaissance
tiens les deux jours plus tard il me
manquait un doigt on avait tué une [ __ ]
je m'y attendais pas du tout
bennett
[Applaudissements]